So we know permissions are represented
as Rs, Ws and Xs, indicating read,
write and execute.
But when we changed the permissions of
some files earlier we used numbers.
How did the digits we entered
translate to these values?
We can translate these
values as follows.
Rs are equal to 4.
W's are equal to two,
X's are equal to one and
if we don't want any permissions,
that will be a zero.
By adding the numbers together,
we end up with a result identifying
the full set of permissions to apply.
For example,
if we wanted to give read and
execute permissions,
we'd have values of four and
one, which when added together,
gives us a final value of five.
To represent, read, and
execute permissions,
you would use the number five.
But remember, permissions are done
in sets of three to identify what
permissions are set for the individual
user, the group, and everyone.
Let's analyze our student's
.bashrc file once again.
And convert its current
permissions into octal form.
The current permissions for
this file are rw dash, r dash dash, and
r dash dash, r is a 4 and write is 2.
So the user value would be 6.
For group, we just have an r.
So the value is 4.
And for everyone we have a value of 4.
To represent this permission set in
octal form, we'd use the value 644.